[Music]
hello i'm scottie meyer from little
light studios and on today's i've got a
question um
we get this question actually a lot why
do i hate hollywood so much uh
first of all i don't really hate
hollywood just for the sake of
hating it and all the people that are in
it um i actually was in love with
hollywood when i finished film school
and i ended up there for 10 years of my
life
i wanted to be there till the day i die
in fact i actually have some
video of me in the very beginning when i
was down there saying i will be here
till the day i die um i was in love with
the business i was in love with
everything that had to do with
entertainment
creating movies film cinema acting you
name it i was really really in in love
with all of it um but when god got a
hold of my heart i started to really
look at the content that i was either
watching creating making
and i started to really analyze like is
this really something that that that i
would do in heaven or is this something
that god would want me to do or is this
is this in line with the bible and what
the bible teaches
and more often than not i found that the
very popular media that i was absolutely
in love with was very against biblical
biblical ideas and so i began to um
really pray to god and say lord
if you don't want me to be here in
hollywood or you don't want me to watch
these movies or you don't want me to be
involved in this industry you have to
change my heart because i love this
place
and i gave god permission to change my
heart and so little by little over time
he changed my taste i i didn't like the
same movies if there was things in it
that that i felt like fought against god
i i would turn away from them turn them
off watch something else and slowly over
time
it literally changed my
tastes for what hollywood was putting
out so i think a a a clarification of
that i don't hate hollywood like what
the bible says hate the sin but not the
sinner i love the people in fact i would
love to reach the people that are out
there in hollywood that are working in
hollywood we've sent our videos handed
them to actors uh when i was in
hollywood i used to give them out to all
sorts of people that were around there
and share with them what i was learning
about god in the bible
but i really really really feel very
strongly about a lot of the content
that's coming out of it and i think that
only comes with a relationship with god
as you draw closer to god
the things of this world will grow
strangely dim in the light and the glory
of his grace
and so that's what happened to me
i don't hate hollywood just for this
reason of hating it
i do not like the type of content
they're putting out because it's
influencing my brothers and sisters
contrary to the word of god and so
pray for them they need a lot of prayer
and
nobody is beyond god's reach anyone
anywhere anytime can be reached by the
gospel or by god so i believe that we
need to put
extra effort in reaching that group
especially because of how influential
they are
so thanks for watching today's i've got
a question and don't forget if you have
a question we want to hear from you
leave it in the comment section below we
take every single one of those comments
seriously and we'll try to answer your
questions in the future thanks for
watching
[Music]
you